Sie ist mir aufgefallen.
Aber ich dachte,
das werde etwas für eine Nacht
und dann reise ich weiter.
"Oh mein Gott,
wie kann man nur so naiv sein?"
"Irgend so ein Typ
vom anderen Ende der Welt."
Wir waren die ganze Zeit
im Internet zusammen.
Ich brach alle Kontakte
mit anderen Personen ab.
Für mich war klar:
Das geht in Richtung Hochzeit.
* Herzschläge *
* Romantische Melodie *
# Take my hand, take me anywhere,
as long as you are there.
# Take my hand.
# Together we will be
forever you and me.
(Radiojingle) SRF 3, Wetter.
Thomas Kleiber, immer
kommt ein weiterer schöner Tag.
Jetzt nur noch zweimal bis Freitag.
Und Schnee bis ganz runter
ist zwar nicht in Sicht, aber Regen.
Vielen Dank, Thomas Kleiber.
Und kann es wirklich sein?
Das letzte Mal, dass du für uns
das Radiowetter gemacht hast?
Sag Nein!
Wenn ich Nein sagte, wäre es
eine Fehlprognose. Ich sage Ja.
Wie ist das Wetter in Quebec?
Ganz ähnlich, ein bisschen kühler,
es hat schon mal etwas geschneit.
Aber sie haben auch
ein nasses Wochenende vor sich.
Das ist der Abschied.
Danke, Thomas Kleiber.
Und wir von SRF 3
und alle Hörerinnen und Hörer
wünschen lauter Hochs
und Schäfchenwolken
in deiner neuen Heimat Kanada.
Vielen Dank. Tschüss, Mona!
(Jahrelang hat uns
Thomas Kleiber gesagt,
ob wir Regenschirm
oder Sonnenbrille brauchen.)
(Jetzt folgt er der Liebe
und wandert nach Kanada aus.)
Es ist ein grosser Schritt.
Es gibt Nächte,
da wache ich auf und denke:
"Spinnst du eigentlich?"
Und dann gibt es Nächte,
da freue ich mich total.
Ich bin neugierig,
das bin ich sowieso.
Und ich weiss,
egal wie dieses Abenteuer ausgeht,
es wird extrem bereichernd sein.
Am Anfang
war ich viel ängstlicher,
jetzt werde ich
immer optimistischer.
* Herzschläge *
Es hat einfach gepasst.
Seine Lebensfreude
und Lebenslust und Unbekümmertheit.
Auch wenn das
für mich als Schweizerin,
die es gerne
ein bisschen strukturierter mag,
manchmal eine Challenge ist,
ist es etwas, das ich schätze
und das mich angezogen hat.
(Katja stammt aus Bischofszell
im Kanton Thurgau.)
(Vor zehn Jahren
war sie in Indonesien surfen.)
(Aus jener Zeit gibt es ein Foto,
bevor sie sich kennenlernten.)
(Sie war
im gleichen Flugzeug wie er.)
(Kurz darauf hat es
zwischen ihnen gefunkt.)
Was machst du?
Sagst du mir nicht mal Hallo?
* Sie spricht unverständlich. *
Du hast Schokolade gegessen?
No!
- Hat Papi auch Schokolade gegessen?
Hello, how are you?
- Good. How are you?
Busy?
- Oh, silly busy.
(Jetzt, zehn Jahre später, wohnen
die beiden mit ihrer Tochter Narja
in Mount Maunganui in Neuseeland.)
Wow.
Ich weiss nicht, ob es
Liebe auf den ersten Blick war,
aber Katja war
fast die einzige Frau auf der Insel.
Ich dachte:
"Oh, wer ist dieses blonde Mädchen?"
Aber ich weiss nicht, ob es
Liebe auf den ersten Blick war.
Aber dieses einzige blonde Girl
in diesem abgelegenen Surfcamp
hatte die Aufmerksamkeit
der ganzen Insel,
also auch meine.
Jedenfalls wurde
ziemlich schnell Liebe daraus.
Definitiv von Anfang an.
Vielleicht war ich
nicht gerade verliebt,
aber ... sehr angetan.
Auf Englisch würde man sagen:
a crush.
Aber offensichtlich
war er der Attraktivste.
Und es ging dann schnell von
Verknalltheit in Verliebtheit über,
innerhalb ein paar Monate.
* Fröhliche Musik: "E Tu Hahi Katea"
von Pulefano and the Polynesians *
(Bevor sie eine Familie wurden,
gab es jede Menge Hin und Her.)
(Zweimal von Neuseeland
in die Schweiz und wieder zurück.)
And jump!
(2014 zogen sie definitiv
ans andere Ende der Welt,
ins Surferparadies.)
(AJ war früher Surfprofi.)
(AJ ist übrigens nur sein Übername,
getauft wurde der Halbmaori
auf den Namen Arjuna.)
(Wenn man ihn und Katja
mit Narja so sieht,
könnte man meinen, man habe sich
in ein Bilderbuch verirrt.)
(Aber nicht nur das Glück
findet einen irgendwann,
sondern auch der Alltag.)
(Und genau dieser Alltag
interessiert uns in dieser Serie
rund um Paare
aus zwei verschiedenen Ländern.)
Für die wahre Liebe
sei kein Weg zu weit, heisst es ja.
Dementsprechend
muss Katja Fitzes Liebe riesig sein,
denn sie ist dem Mann ihres Lebens
ans andere Ende der Welt gefolgt.
Nach Neuseeland.
(Das ist die Westküste
der Nordinsel Neuseelands.)
(Wir sind hier am Strand verabredet.)
Die Frage ist ...
... wo wir sie finden.
Ich weiss nur, dass sie blond ist,
und ihre Tochter ist auch blond.
Und AJ muss man wohl irgendwo da
draussen suchen und nicht am Strand.
Diese Person ist schon mal blond,
aber ohne Kind.
Ich glaube, das sind sie.
Sind wir hier richtig?
- Ja.
Katja? Mona, hallo.
Ich hatte schon Angst, dass ich
eine wildfremde Blondine anspreche.
Hey.
- AJ, great to meet you.
I'm Mona.
- Hi, Mona, how are things?
Very good.
Sagst du auch Hallo?
Hoi.
Oh, hast du schon ein Eis bekommen?
Wow! Wie heisst du denn?
Wer bist denn du?
Big girl.
- Big girl.
Ah, big girl!
- Das ist Mona.
Sagst du Hallo zu Mona?
- Mona.
Mona, genau.
Und du?
Verstehst du Schweizerdeutsch?
Ich verstehe ein paar Bruchstücke.
Ich lebte eine Zeit lang in der
Schweiz, so verstehe ich ein wenig.
Ich weiss, wenn man über mich redet!
Wo habt ihr euch
das erste Mal getroffen?
Es war in Indonesien,
auch am Strand.
Es war auf Sumbawa.
How can you not remember?
Sumbawa.
Als ich ihn traf, dachte:
"Ah, Neuseeländer,
den werde ich nie mehr sehen."
Du dachtest also,
das sei einfach etwas Spass?
Genau, ein Ferienflirt.
Ich war damals auf Weltreise,
bestimmt schon etwa fünf Monate.
Nach sechs Monaten hätte ich nach
Hause sollen, zurück an die Uni.
Aber dann ... habe ich
das Ganze etwas verlängert.
Wir haben in Bali rumgehangen,
dann kam sie nach Neuseeland.
Dann waren wir in der Schweiz.
Und jetzt sind wir hier
mit unserem grossen Mädchen.
Nearly nine and a half years later.
(Katja ging noch mal in die Schweiz,
um ihr Studium abzuschliessen,
und 2014 zogen sie nach Auckland.)
(Heute wohnen sie drei Autostunden
von Auckland entfernt,
in Maunganui, direkt am Meer.)
Noch weiter raus?
Siehst du Papi? Dort draussen.
Ah!
- Runter? War das zu schnell?
(Die Neuseeländer sind,
wie wir Schweizer,
stolz auf ihre schöne Natur
und Landschaft.)
(Und sie sind
ein sportbegeistertes Volk.)
(Mit Katja und AJ steige ich auf
den Hausberg von Mount Maunganui.)
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Der ist ganz schnell.
* Mona atmet schwer. *
Wo ist AJ? Schon oben?
- Wahrscheinlich schon.
Jetzt ist AJ wenigstens wieder
in Sichtweite, aber vorher ...
Wie der den Berg hochzieht!
Ist das sein Training
oder ist er einfach so ungeduldig?
Eher ungeduldig. Es ist nicht so,
dass wir jeden Abend hier hochgehen.
Das ist eher seine Ungeduld.
Dieses Hang Loose der Surfer,
das hat er gar nicht.
Er ist getaktet.
- Das hat er weniger, ja.
Das hat er nicht so.
Es sei denn, er hat einen Kater.
Was ab und zu vorkommt.
Aber sonst ist er eher on the go,
die meiste Zeit.
Wie ist es bei euch?
Seid ihr euch ähnlich
oder gilt: Gegensätze ziehen sich an?
Sorry.
- Hey.
Wir sind beide
eher etwas ungeduldig.
Wir machen etwas
lieber heute als morgen.
Bei mir ist es manchmal zu sehr so,
dass ich nicht so viel
darüber nachdenke und sage:
"Das wird schon klappen."
Das ist vielleicht der Grund,
warum ich hier bin.
Ich denke nicht so sehr
über die Konsequenzen nach.
Ich werfe mich einfach rein.
Willst du sagen, du warst etwas naiv
und bist einfach hergekommen?
Zu einem gewissen Grad
vielleicht schon.
Ist das nötig für
solch einen Riesenschritt, so jung?
Ja, ich denke schon.
Und wenn man jung ist,
ist man tendenziell sowieso naiver.
Es gibt vielleicht einige,
die nicht so sind,
aber mit Anfang 20
ist man doch etwas naiv.
Yeah!
* Lachen *
Hier sind sie.
Bist du mit Papi hochgerannt?
- Ja!
"Mamam"! Deine Hände rutschen weg.
Du hältst dich ja gar nicht fest.
Wieso sprichst du mit ihr
Schweizerdeutsch und nicht Englisch?
Sicher mal wegen meiner Mutter.
Sie spricht zwar etwas Englisch,
aber nicht so gut.
Und auch, weil es meine Sprache ist
und meine ...
... Identität.
Oder ein Teil meiner Identität.
Deshalb ist mir wichtig,
dass sie Schweizerdeutsch versteht.
(Vor ein paar Jahren legte sich
ein Schatten über das Glück.)
(Katjas Vater starb plötzlich.)
(Seither ist Katjas Sehnsucht
nach der Schweiz grösser geworden.)
Warum?
Um mit meiner Familie zu sein und
weil ich nur noch meine Mutter habe.
Mein Vater ist gestorben.
Deshalb ... Ja, ihretwegen.
Und wegen Freunden.
Das wünschst du dir?
Das ist das, was du hier vermisst?
Ja, doch.
Ich werde ganz sentimental
hier oben.
(Mit zittriger Stimme) Damit sie ...
Ich sehe ja, wie sehr sie sie mag.
Das erste Enkelkind.
Sie verpasst so viel.
Und auch für mich.
Und AJ versteht das.
Er weiss, dass ich mehr Heimweh
habe, seit Narja hier ist.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Na?
Ja, schau mal, du Bohne!
Sag:
"Papi, du bist eine Nervensäge."
Kannst du das sagen?
- Nervensäge.
Gut, gehen wir.
* Herzschläge *
Er hat angefangen.
Wir haben gechattet,
aber es war sehr kurz:
"Du bist aus Kanada? Cool.
Ich bin aus der Schweiz." "Cool."
Fertig.
Dann nach ein paar Wochen wieder.
Und so begannen wir zu schreiben.
Wir hatten ähnliche Interessen.
Die Konversationen
wurde immer lustiger,
also wollten wir mal skypen.
Er log aber und sagte,
das Mikrofon sei kaputt,
weil er zu schüchtern war.
Ich musste also schreiben.
Aber wir begannen zu skypen
und merkten immer mehr,
dass wir dieselben Interessen
und Vorstellungen hatten.
Und dann machte er
den mutigen Schritt und sagte:
"Virtuell funktioniert es. Klappt
es auch, wenn wir uns treffen?"
Das hat dann aber ...
It took about five months?
Etwa fünf Monate später
kam er in die Schweiz.
Und dann ...
- Oui.
... funktionierte es sehr gut.
* Sanfte Melodie *
(So richtig glücklich ist David
in der Schweiz aber nicht geworden.)
(Deshalb versuchen sie es
jetzt umgekehrt.)
(Thomas Kleiber
packt seine Siebensachen
und zieht in ein paar Tagen
nach Quebec.)
Ja, vieles ist schon weg.
Viele Sachen konnte ich
meiner Familie überlassen
oder auch Freunden.
Einen Teil
habe ich sonst verscherbelt.
Es ist ziemlich ...
Ja, es ist kein Wohnzimmer mehr.
Aber den Tisch
behalte ich auf jeden Fall,
der gehörte meinem Grossvater.
Die Stühle kommen weg,
aber der Tisch ist super.
Mir ist schon bewusst,
dass es ein Abschied ist,
aber es ist ...
Wenn ich die Sachen wegräume,
die ich mit David zusammen hatte,
dann ist es etwas merkwürdig,
denn dann denke ich
an unsere schöne Zeit hier.
Aber die Wohnung selbst ...
Das Gehen ist etwas anderes. Das
Weggehen aus der Schweiz wird hart.
(Thomas und David
waren noch nicht lange zusammen,
als der Kanadier
für zwei Jahre nach Zürich zog.)
Wenn es ernst wird,
reden wir Englisch miteinander,
dann sind wir beide
etwa gleich benachteiligt.
Aber wir haben immer versucht,
abzuwechseln.
Einen Tag Deutsch,
einen Tag Französisch.
Wir waren mässig diszipliniert,
aber manchmal
haben wir es wirklich durchgezogen.
Immer wenn Französisch anstand,
hat v.a. David geredet.
Er ist seit ein paar Monaten
in Kanada,
also ist die einfach
als Erinnerung hier.
Der Lebensstil in Zürich
hat mir sehr gefallen.
Man kann alles mit dem Fahrrad,
mit dem Tram oder dem Zug erreichen.
Das habe ich geliebt.
Aber meine Freunde waren nicht da.
Mein ganzes Umfeld hat gefehlt.
Die Leute, die ich liebe.
Na ja, die Familie, die Freunde.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Er wollte nach Hause,
er kommt aus einem schönen Land,
hat eine tolle Familie,
tolle Freunde.
Und ich fand es unfair, zu sagen,
unsere Beziehung funktioniere nur,
wenn er in mein Land komme.
Und ich war neugierig auf Kanada.
Seine Familie ist grossartig,
ich habe einen super Draht zu ihnen.
Sie sind sehr nett,
seine Freunde auch.
Quebec - nette Menschen.
Jetzt versuchen wir es mal. Aber
ihm gefällt die Schweiz schon auch.
* Sanfte Melodie *
(David wohnt noch
bei seiner Familie.)
(Das war so,
bevor er nach Zürich zog,
und es ist auch jetzt wieder so,
nach seiner Rückkehr nach Quebec.)
(David ist 28 Jahre alt,
19 Jahre jünger
als der ehemalige "SRF Meteo"-Mann.)
(Vielleicht sei er damals einfach
noch nicht für den grossen Schritt
bereit gewesen, die Eltern und
die Heimat hinter sich zu lassen.)
Es ist klar, dass meine Familie
mein ganzes Leben lang
meine treibende Kraft war.
Wir haben zusammen 23, 24 Jahre
in derselben Wohnung gewohnt.
Wir waren immer zusammen.
Auch in den Ferien.
Alles hat sich hier abgespielt.
Auch mit den Freunden.
Aber meine Gefühle gegenüber Thomas
waren so stark,
dass ich es probieren wollte.
Es war eine grosse Entscheidung,
die du getroffen hattest.
Und wir hatten schon
ein wenig Bedenken,
als du diesen Schritt
in die Schweiz machtest,
um zu schauen,
wie es mit Thomas weitergeht.
Das war
eine schwierige Entscheidung.
(Die ersten Schritte in
ein neues Leben mögen aufregend sein,
die letzten Schritte im alten Leben
sind aber auch nicht ohne.)
(Im Herbst 2018
steht Thomas Kleiber zum letzten Mal
in Zürich
auf dem Dach des Fernsehstudios.)
Im Norden am Samstag
z.T. auch Hochnebel.
Auch wenn die Details noch unsicher
sind im Lauf der neuen Woche,
klar ist, es bleibt mild.
Meine Damen und Herren,
jetzt muss ich intervenieren.
Wir müssen nämlich
Abschied von dir nehmen, Thomas.
Das war deine allerletzte
"Meteo"-Sendung.
Die Liebe zieht dich nach Kanada.
Du wirst auswandern.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
* Herzschläge *
Er stand so dort.
Das war wirklich ...
Das ist einfach seine Natur,
seine Haltung.
Sein Charakter,
seine Haltung, sein Stolz.
Er kommt wirklich aus einem Stamm,
der sehr stolz ist.
Als Nakota gehört er
zu den Sioux-Stämmen.
Das waren Prärie-Indianer,
das waren sehr grosse Krieger.
Daher ist das also schon
in den Genen drin.
* Indianische Flötenklänge, Gesang *
(Brigitte und Jay hatten beide
eine Scheidung hinter sich,
als sie sich
im Internet kennenlernten.)
(Und beide
sind im Nachhinein überzeugt,
dass es genau so kommen musste.)
Beautiful, beautiful!
(Seit 2011 sind die Schweizerin
und der stolze Nakota verheiratet.)
(Brigitte war Köchin,
Jay war gelernter Verhaltenstrainer
und ist heute
als Lastwagenfahrer unterwegs.)
Bye, take care! Drive safe!
Bye, sweetie!
(Am Anfang mussten Brigitte und Jay
immer wieder
sprachliche Barrieren überwinden.)
(Aber im Alltag
und den Gewohnheiten der Nakota
hat sie sich sehr schnell
zurechtgefunden und wohlgefühlt.)
Bevor ich so eine Arbeit mache,
räuchere ich immer.
Ein Gebet, mit dem ich um Hilfe
bitte, damit meine Hand ruhigbleibt,
damit meine Gedanken
voller Liebe sind.
Und damit die Person,
für die ich diese Dinge mache,
glücklich darüber sein wird.
(Die Bernerin schätzt ihr Leben im
Einklang mit der Natur von Montana.)
(Und auch wenn sie
ab und zu allein ist,
hat sie ihren Platz und ihre Aufgaben
in der Stammesgemeinschaft gefunden.)
Diese Mokassins
sind ein Auftrag meines Schwagers.
Ich habe mir im Internet,
mit YouTube-Videos,
von denen es viele gibt,
beigebracht, wie man sie macht.
Das gehört zu den Aufgaben,
die mir Jay übergeben hat.
Solche Arbeiten ...
Es ist eigentlich eine Ehre,
wenn ein Familienmitglied
auf einen zukommt und sich wünscht,
dass man ihm
dieses oder jenes macht.
Das ist eine Ehre und man kann
eigentlich nicht Nein sagen.
Was ich hier mache,
ist ganz traditionell.
Das ist ein lazy stitch,
also ein fauler Stich auf Deutsch.
Und das bedeutet, ich nehme
eine bestimmte Anzahl Perlen
und steche dann hier unten rein.
* Sanfte Musik *
(Brigitte hat mit Jay ein
völlig neues Leben kennengelernt.)
(Und auch für Jay hat sich
dank Brigitte vieles verändert.)
Sie half mir,
wieder zu mir zu finden.
Ich war verloren, komplett zerstört
von der letzten Scheidung.
Brigitte ist super.
Sie lehrte mich Geduld, Liebe,
machte wieder
einen positiven Menschen aus mir.
Sie lehrte mich,
dass ich der bin, der ich bin.
Ich müsse nur wieder zu mir finden.
Und das stimmt.
Sie macht mich schon glücklich,
wenn ich an sie denke.
Das hier sind meine.
Meine Mokassins.
Das hier ist das Symbol
für meinen Namen.
Weisser Bär aus der Ferne.
Te'handoa mato ska.
Mato heisst Bär.
Ska ist weiss.
Und te'handoa heisst so viel wie:
ist von weit entfernt hergekommen.
Und das ist Nakota.
Die verstorbene Frau meines
Schwiegervaters gab mir den Namen.
Denn sie sagte,
sie hätte das Gefühl,
dass ich diese innerliche
Bärenkraft besitze.
Und das muss ja stimmen, denn ich
bin schliesslich in Bern geboren!
* Sanfte Musik *
(Dass Brigitte für ihre Liebe zu Jay
so weit gereist ist,
beeindruckt ihn heute noch.)
Sie hat alles
hinter sich gelassen für mich.
Ich sehe das als grosses Kompliment.
Sie liebte mich wirklich
und so musste ich ganz einfach
lernen, sie ebenso zu lieben.
* Herzschläge *
Ich bin eher jemand,
der wissen will,
was morgen, übermorgen
oder in einer Woche läuft.
Hier in Neuseeland hingegen ...
... oder v.a. AJ
ist von dieser Surfkultur geprägt.
Es ist mehr so, dass man im Heute
lebt, das Heute ist wichtig.
Morgen ist morgen.
Er hat zu einem gewissen Grad
etwas von meiner Sicht übernommen.
Und ich von ihm - dass man wirklich
auch das Heute geniessen muss,
das Beste daraus macht und nicht
immer nur in die Zukunft blickt.
Klar, man muss
in die Zukunft blicken,
aber man muss auch das Heute
geniessen und schätzen.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
(Auch im Paradies beginnt der Alltag
in aller Herrgottsfrühe.)
(Um 5.30 Uhr ist Katja
bereits aufgestanden.)
(Sie muss zur Arbeit.)
Ich hasse es,
die Spülmaschine auszuräumen.
Ähm ...
Es gibt eigentlich keine klare
Regel. Wer gerade Zeit hat.
Obwohl, mit dem Ausräumen warte ich
normalerweise, bis AJ es macht.
Meistens - denn ich hasse es.
Aber er macht wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen mehr im Haushalt,
wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Er ist auch besser.
Man muss es dem überlassen,
der es am besten macht.
Vielleicht mache ich es nicht
so gerne, weil ich 100 % arbeite.
Wenn ich mehr zu Hause wäre,
dann vielleicht ...
Nein, auch dann
wahrscheinlich nicht.
Das gute neuseeländische Brot!
Frisch und knusprig!
Dieses Brot ist so ...
... überhaupt nicht knusprig, aber
trotzdem isst Narja die Rinde nicht.
Sie braucht noch etwas Training, um
eine richtige Schweizerin zu werden.
Wenn es nach ihr ginge,
würde sie nur Schokolade essen.
Deshalb habe ich angefangen, die
Sachen mit Förmchen auszustechen,
damit sie wenigstens
etwas interessant aussehen.
So.
Tada!
Guten Morgen!
Bist du schon wach?
Sind das deine Füsse?
Und wer ist das?
Wer ist das?
- Mikey.
Mikey?
* Sanfte Klänge *
Monkey?
(Wenn Katja und ihre Familie
am Morgen aufstehen,
ist bei ihrer Mutter in der Schweiz
bereits Abend.)
(Und erst noch einer
mit einem Familienfest.)
Hoi.
- Sternli.
Hast du einen Stern?
Hoi.
- Hoi.
Hoi, Roger.
Hoi, Dani. Hoi, Judith.
Oh, Luisa! Hoi.
* Kindergeschrei *
Schau mal, hier ist Cedi.
Ich habe gesehen,
dass er jetzt läuft.
Wenn man ihre Cousinen
und Cousins sieht,
die jetzt alle viel grösser
als beim letzten Mal sind,
merkt man,
wie schnell die Zeit vergeht
und wie viel man verpasst
oder nicht sieht.
* Kindergeschrei *
(Frau) Pass auf, die Ecke!
Das ist dann ein bisschen traurig.
Nicht wahr, Narja?
Sagt du Oma noch Tschüss?
Sagst du Tschüss?
- Tschüss, Oma.
Tschüss.
Ich ziehe mich an.
I'll go and get dressed.
You'll watch her?
- Yeah.
* Schnelle, verspielte Musik *
Gehen wir, Schätzchen?
- Bye bye.
Einsteigen! Andere Seite.
(Der Alltag einer
berufstätigen Mutter mit Kleinkind
sieht, egal auf welcher Seite der
Erde, wohl überall etwas gleich aus.)
Und dann holt dich Papa ab?
Ja?
Okay.
Tschüss.
Tschüss!
- Bye.
Bye, see you later.
Yeah, you close it now? Good girl.
(Narja bleibt tagsüber
bei ihrer Tagesmutter.)
(Und ich will jetzt wissen,
ob eine Bank
überall auf der Welt so ist,
wie wir sie kennen,
oder ob es bei der
Bank of New Zealand anders läuft.)
Ich glaube,
hier ist noch geschlossen.
Sonst bin ich nie so früh hier.
Gehörst du zu jenen, die ...
- ... eher spät anfangen.
Morning.
- Good morning.
Hi, how are you?
It's going across
other side of the world.
I'm very pleased with that.
True?
- No!
Thank you.
Das Speziellste haben wir
noch gar nicht gesehen.
Katja sagte,
so etwas gäbe es in der Schweiz nie.
Bei uns würde man
einen Brunch oder Apero machen.
Und in Neuseeland ...
... grillieren wir
Würstchen zum Frühstück.
Morning.
- Good morning.
Hello.
- Wow!
Ja, das isst man bei uns weniger.
* Lachen *
What time is it?
Ten past seven.
- Wow!
In the morning!
Also, es ist 7.10 Uhr.
You are the first people
I've ever seen in my life
who are doing barbecue
at this time of the day.
Wow!
Musstest du dich
an solche Sachen gewöhnen?
Ja. Ich esse auch jetzt
noch keine Würstchen zum Frühstück.
Aber es ist schon toll.
We probably do it the best.
Ich wollte nie
einen Schweizer heiraten.
Ich weiss nicht wieso.
Schon seit meiner Kindheit.
Meine Eltern wussten das,
ich sagte das immer.
Frag mich nicht, wieso. Ich habe das
einfach immer schon gewusst.
Und es klingt vielleicht ein
bisschen blöd, wenn man das so hört,
aber das war einfach ein Gefühl.
Vermutlich hatte das
mit meiner Bestimmung zu tun.
Ich habe immer gewusst ...
Mein Ex-Mann war kein Fehler.
Am Anfang waren wir sehr glücklich.
Wir haben uns einfach
auseinandergelebt.
Aber es war nicht das,
was hätte sein sollen.
* Indianische Flötenklänge,
Gesang *
(Das, was hätte sein sollen,
sieht so aus.)
(Die Weite der Prärie, das Gefühl
der Freiheit, die Nähe zur Natur
und Jay an ihrer Seite.)
Yeppa, sweet pea.
Let's sit right there.
Come on, old girl, you can do it.
There you go, woman.
How pretty that is!
(Bevor die Köchin aus Bern
und der Verhaltenstherapeut vom Stamm
der Nakota zueinanderfanden,
brauchte es aber nicht nur
einen Wink des Schicksals,
sondern auch den Segen
der modernen Technik.)
* Kauzrufe *
Unsere Geschichte begann damit:
Ich hatte eine Freundin,
die mir von Match.com erzählte.
Und zwar nicht nur, um einen Partner
für eine Beziehung zu finden,
sondern einfach Bekanntschaften -
socialising.
Ich habe ein bisschen rumgestöbert
und habe Jays Profil gesehen.
Und sein Lachen und seine
strahlenden Augen gefielen mir.
Ich dachte:
"Dem muss ich schreiben!"
Ich hatte ein Dreitages-Probeabo.
Da musst du nichts bezahlen.
Du kannst dein Profil erstellen
und ein Foto hochladen.
Ich habe das
an einem Freitag gemacht.
Und am Sonntag haben wir schon
ausserhalb der Plattform
miteinander geschrieben.
Wir haben uns hin und her
geschrieben, über Alltägliches.
Fragen wie:
"Was machst du? Was arbeitest du?"
"Wo wohnst du?"
Und das für mehr als neun Monate.
Wir hatten vorher
nie miteinander gesprochen.
Dann stand ich am Flughafen,
und als sie runterkam, dachte ich:
"Wow, wie auf dem Foto!"
Sie kam auf mich zu
und ich stand nur da.
Dann habe ich ihren Arm berührt
und es fühlte sich an
wie ein elektrischer Schlag.
Wir schauten uns an und ich fragte:
"Hast du das auch gespürt?"
Und sie sagte Ja. Boom!
Und dann
küsste ich sie auf den Mund,
und ich wusste, dass es
die Wahrheit war, als ich ihr sagte:
"Ich werde dich heiraten."
Natürlich glaubte sie mir das nicht,
aber ich heiratete sie dann.
Und jetzt bin ich glücklich.
* Schleppende Gitarrenklänge *
Ich mag die Schweiz, es ist
mein Heimatland, ich bin Schweizer.
Das ist man automatisch,
und all das zurückzulassen,
z.B. auch ...
Das Selbstbewusstsein - im eigenen
Land versteht man die Sprache,
man versteht,
wie das Land funktioniert.
Man weiss, wie man sich in einem
Land verteidigt und platziert.
Man kennt die Spielregeln.
All das lässt man zurück -
man kommt in ein fremdes Land,
man ist quasi schwach,
unsicher und verletzlich.
Ja, das.
(Im letzten Herbst
war Thomas bereit,
alles Vertraute und die Sicherheit
der Schweiz zurückzulassen.)
Was hier drin so alles lebt!
Es ist lustig -
jedes Jahr ist es wieder anders.
Es gibt Molche,
es gibt Kröten, es gibt Frösche.
Und manchmal gibt es Anfang Sommer
Tausende von kleinen Kröten,
die sich bereit machen,
ihr Leben ausserhalb des Weihers
in Angriff zu nehmen.
Solche Dinge sind einfach genial.
Das werde ich vermissen.
Aber ich werde einen Weg finden.
Unten kann man entwässern.
Also, tschüss!
(Mit seinem Bruder besucht er
noch einmal den gemeinsamen Garten
über dem Greifensee, wo sich die
Familie immer wieder getroffen hat.)
Das muss man absaugen.
(Thomas Kleiber stellt
ziemlich viel in seinem Leben
auf einen Schlag auf den Kopf.)
(Er tauscht nicht nur
ein Leben als öffentliche Person
mit der Anonymität in Kanada,
er lässt auch Freunde, Bekannte
und seine Familie zurück.)
... eher Ende Mai,
er ist immer spät.
An Anfang hatte ich Mühe damit,
dass er weggeht.
Heute muss ich aber sagen,
dass es genial ist,
denn wer hat je gesagt, er mache
eine Veränderung, und hat es bereut?
Das ist ...
Ich finde es genial, dass er geht.
Er verlässt seine Komfortzone.
Und nur wer die Komfortzone
verlässt, kann weiterkommen.
Wenn man in der Komfortzone bleibt,
dann ... herrscht Alltag.
Es ist schon so: Du hast Kinder,
du hast eine Familie.
Das ist vergleichbar
mit einem Projekt,
die Kinder sind jedes Jahr, also
jeden Tag eine neue Herausforderung.
Wenn man keine Kinder hat, merkt
man, wie sich jedes Jahr gleicht.
Irgendwann denkt man:
"Ich will auch noch etwas erleben."
Klar, es ist ein egoistischer
Entscheid euch gegenüber.
Aber ich sage nicht,
dass ich für immer gehe,
und so weit ist Kanada
letztlich auch nicht entfernt.
Wer kann schon sagen, dass er
seinen grossen Bruder loswird?
Ja, auf elegante Art!
Nein, tipptopp.
Das könnte ich noch wegräumen.
* Herzschläge *
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
(Nächste Woche sehen wir, wie
Thomas Kleiber endgültig Adieu sagt.)
Emotional
sind diese Wechsel nicht einfach.
(Aber so einfach, wie es wirkt,
ist es auch in Neuseeland nicht.)
Kompromisse muss man
in jeder Partnerschaft eingehen,
aber in einer
internationalen Partnerschaft
sind es vielleicht
noch grössere Kompromisse.
(Und wir lernen nächste Woche
Lana und Martin kennen.)
Ich bin im Moment
ziemlich genau 10 kg schwerer
als zum Zeitpunkt,
als wir geheiratet haben.